I had a number of people in Washington
in the State Department and elsewhere
telling me very early on all the way
back 18 years ago put the focus on
Pakistan Pakistan is going to be the
most dangerous state for all of us and
that was the head of policy planning at
the time a man named sam lewis who said
that that week and i said well is that
the number one item for policy planning
long-term planning from the center me he
said you better did well it still is and
it's more urgent now than it was then we
did pay attention to him we've done a
number of pieces on not just Pakistan
but the dynamics of that region and how
easily they come unraveled but this was
long before nine eleven and long before
Afghanistan was viewed as anything but a
backwater after the Soviet invasion was
was over so I still remember that
neither the State Department or foreign
affairs really grasped at that time just
what a problem Pakistan could end up to
be now why do I call it a big problem
now Pakistan is a major state it's not
like Afghanistan a backwater state it
has a big population a lot of big
military nuclear weapons and one of the
great nation to nation conflicts that
still goes on if there's going to be
another big nation-to-nation war it's
more likely to be between India and
Pakistan than almost anybody else we
have been completely unsuccessful not
that we haven't tried and I say we I
mean the United States in getting
Pakistan and India to finally resolve
the problems of Kashmir and get back
into a more normal state-to-state
relationship putting the emphasis on
their economic developments in that
period of time those 18 years or so
since that first warning Pakistan has
gone through a great discombobulation
civil governments that didn't work
military Terry Crews's in work the rise
of fundamentalism there
meanwhile across the border India has
gone from being a relatively huge
poverty-ridden country with very few
prospects for economic development into
this raging new first-rate power with
which is where they're headed with a
very dynamic economy and so you have
this contest between a fading Pakistan
if you will and a rising India and that
of course is the garmins for even more
attentions and possible miscalculations
well one has to assume if there really
was an another all-out Indian Pakistani
war that nuclear weapons would be used
and what the specific ramifications
would be it's hard to say but a nuclear
war there's only been one use of nuclear
weapons ever is an incalculable on risk
with unintended consequences we are both
an ally of Pakistan and we are an ally
of India what would we do if the two of
them ended up in the war what would we
do with one starting using nuclear
weapons I don't know but it is it is a
cataclysm to be avoided at all costs